Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buongiorno a tutti, sono qui per parlarvi di agriurbanismo,
una nuova disciplina che è nata proprio
per cercare di regolare il rapporto tra spazi urbani e spazi agricoli.
Questa necessità è emersa in realtà circa due secoli fa in Europa,
a seguito delle grandi trasformazioni settecentesche,
che hanno portato al fenomeno dell'inurbamento
e quindi all'abbandono della campagna.
Questo ha decretato la vincita del modello urbano su quello rurale
e ha innescato un conflitto tra la città e la campagna,
in particolare per l'occupazione degli spazi e la gestione delle risorse.
Quindi nell'800 hanno iniziato a ragionare su come si poteva pianificare,
gestire il rapporto tra spazi agricoli e rurali
e questi sono i primi modelli degli utopisti Owen e Howard,
proprio per cercare di capire come gestire, pianificare questi spazi,
ma anche come gestire il conflitto che stava emergendo
tra differenti classi sociali.
A questi modelli hanno fatto riferimento poi delle soluzioni pratiche,
degli schemi di pianificazione reali che si sono però adattati
e hanno cercato di regolare questo rapporto in realtà esistenti,
quindi non in città utopiche, teoriche.
A queste realtà, chiaramente differenti,
sono state trovate tre soluzioni diverse,
che si possono ricondurre, appunto, a tre categorie diverse:
quella della cintura verde, che tende a concentrare la crescita urbana,
perché l'obiettivo era proprio di limitare l'espansione urbana all'interno;
quella di cuneo verde, che consente l'inserimento dell'agricoltura
e della natura verso la città;
e quella del cuore verde, in cui c'è un mantenimento
degli spazi di natura e agricoltura all'interno.
Il problema, il conflitto tra città e campagna, però,
non è determinato solo dall'espansione della città,
ma anche dalle trasformazioni del settore agricolo.
Infatti, lo sviluppo di tecniche di conservazione degli alimenti,
la diffusione di mezzi di trasporto veloce, e anche
l'intensificazione dell'agricoltura e la sua industrializzazione,
tutto questo porta a una deterritorializzazione delle coltivazioni
e l'agricoltura tende a basarsi su logiche di mercato sempre più globali,
quindi le città non considerano più importante mantenere gli spazi agricoli
intorno a loro per avere un approvvigionamento alimentare.
Quindi continua un'espansione urbana
che porta a un consumo di suolo agricolo,
ma a partire dagli anni '70 c'è anche un fenomeno inverso,
cioè quello della rururbanizzazione,
cioè della urbanizzazione delle campagne,
e anche quello porta a una perdita e a un consumo di suolo agricolo.
Ma cosa succede nelle aree che si sviluppano intorno alle città,
quindi nelle aree periurbane? In queste aree, ovviamente,
si sono localizzate anche altre attività, oltre a quelle agricole:
quelle industriali, quelle commerciali, quelle residenziali.
Però in questi territori, che appunto aumentano la loro complessità
sia da un punto di vista ambientale che economico che sociale,
per il numero di attività presenti
ma anche per il numero di attori diversi,
che chiaramente entrano in conflitto tra loro per l'uso dello spazio,
è presente un'agricoltura fragile, frammentata,
che però ha una grossa potenzialità: è più dinamica, è più pronta,
grazie priprio alla vicinanza della città,
a rispondere alle nuove richieste,
alle nuove esigenze che fanno la città e i cittadini.
Quindi proprio queste aree agricole periurbane sono considerate le aree
che possono riqualificare un nuovo rapporto tra la città e la campagna.
Come fare per mantenere queste aree?
Intanto è importante riconoscere il loro valore sociale,
politico ed economico.
È importante quindi mantenere i terreni agricoli e cercare degli strumenti
per evitare l'urbanizzazione e il consumo di suolo,
ma oltre a questo è importante anche capire come gestire questi spazi.
Proprio per questo sono nati dei progetti specifici,
che cercano un nuovo equilibrio tra la città e la campagna,
tra il governo del territorio e l'agricoltura; delle forme che sono
riconoscibili in modelli ad hoc, in base ai territori in cui si sviluppano,
che comunque hanno potenziato una multifunzionalità dell'agricoltura,
che tende a rispondere alle nuove esigenze dei cittadini
in termini di prodotti freschi, di qualità,
filiera a chilometro zero e mantenimento di paesaggio e ambiente.
Quindi alcuni modelli che si sono sviluppati come parchi agricoli,
o in Francia, per esempio, i progetti agriurbani,
tendono proprio a rispondere a queste nuove necessità.
Questi sono esempi che hanno avuto successo,
perché hanno capito come valorizzare, potenziare le risorse territoriali,
le risorse endogene dei territori,
trovando a volte anche delle risorse esogene
soprattutto economiche e questi modelli sono riusciti ad avere successo,
perché si sono basati su una partecipazione
di tutti gli attori del territorio,
che hanno partecipato a co-costruire insieme gli spazi
e quindi a capire come gestire il rapporto tra la città e la campagna.
Ovviamente questi modelli sono specifici
in base ai territori in cui si sviluppano,
infatti c'è chi sostiene che il territorio periurbano è un terzo spazio,
e quindi l'agricoltura periurbana ha delle caratteristiche simili,
hanno delle connotazioni simili.
In realtà, a seconda dei territori in cui si sviluppano,
si possono ritrovare vari tipi di agricoltura diversa, quindi se ci si basa
su un approccio disciplinare più vicino allo sviluppo locale,
si può dire che in base ai territori possiamo ritrovare tanti diversi tipi
di agricoltura, ognuna delle quali deve trovare un modello di sviluppo
per potersi mantenere e potenziare.
Agricoltura a cui viene riconosciuta sempre di più una funzione
non solo di tipo produttivo ma protettivo, ecologico, paesaggistico,
culturale e di preservazione dell'ambiente.
Agricoltura che viene tutelata e mantenuta non solo intorno alle città
ma anche dentro alle città, in cui ormai si presenta
in forme sempre più diverse: quelle degli orti, dei giardini,
dei tetti verdi e delle pareti verticali.
Le città si stanno attivando proprio per arrivare anche
a modelli di sviluppo che integrano tutte le risorse dei territori,
quindi a ritrovare uno sviluppo che parta dalle risorse locali.
Un esempio di questi nuovi modelli sono le “transition town”,
che si basano proprio su strategie che mettono in rete
tutte le potenzialità presenti nelle città, tutte le risorse,
cercando anche di riattivare relazioni
e anche un mutuo riconoscimento del saper fare pratico,
per cercare di creare dei beni piuttosto che produrre delle merci,
come abbiamo fatto fino ad ora.
Importanti sono anche le strategie
che si stanno attivando in città come Parigi o Milano,
in cui si sta cercando di ricostruire un legame nuovo
tra la città e la campagna,
incrementando il numero di spazi naturali e agricoli
sia all'interno che all'esterno della città.
Esempi importanti sono anche quelli di Cuba e di Milano, molto diversi,
ma che sono importanti perché si basano su un potenziamento
dell'agricoltura urbana e suburbana,
nel caso di Cuba proprio per rispondere al picco del petrolio e quindi
per favorire un autoapprovvigionamento alimentare di cui hanno bisogno,
o nel caso di Londra invece dove hanno scelto, appunto,
di coltivare gli spazi che sono ancora in transizione,
cioè degli spazi che sono in cerca di una destinazione d'uso.
Ma chi progetta questi spazi, chi è che definisce le strategie di azione
e chi capisce cosa è meglio fare per gestire queste nuove realtà?
Ovviamente sono necessarie molteplici competenze che sono quelle
degli urbanisti, economisti, architetti, agronomi, ecologisti e così via,
ma spesso è difficile, anche lavorando in equipe e integrando le competenze,
capire qual è la soluzione migliore, proprio perché ogni professione,
ogni ambito professionale tende ad essere condizionato dalla sua formazione
e quindi recentemente ricercatori e professionisti
stanno insieme cercando di capire
quale potrebbe essere un nuovo approccio disciplinare,
un nuovo metodo per gestire questi spazi.
Questo dibattito è in corso in paesi diversi e chiaramente,
secondo le caratteristiche socioeconomiche e culturali dei vari paesi,
sta assumendo caratteristiche diverse e sicuramente avrà esiti diversi.
Ma l'obiettivo comune è proprio capire come gestire questi nuovi spazi
e come gestire questo nuovo rapporto tra la città e la campagna
e probabilmente, anche se è un processo molto lungo, è necessario passare
da un approccio specialistico, quello che abbiamo avuto fino ad ora,
verso un approccio olistico, che è capace di capire queste nuove relazioni
e la complessità di questi nuovi spazi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)